we're gonna do all the numbers on
numberphile we've done a lot of the
numbers some would say but we haven't
done all the numbers originally we did
the whole numbers and these are the
classics Mica's we've done 11 that was
in the early one we've done three four
three five seventeen right all the whole
numbers sitting here but then there are
other types of numbers if we go one step
out the rational numbers the ones that
are ratios these are you know you get a
seventeenth you get I don't know things
over a twelve you get all sorts of sand
there you got all the rational numbers
we've gone beyond that day and the
rationals technically include the whole
numbers there are subsets that I'm doing
this as what people call Venn diagram
which is wrong it's an Euler diagram
because I'm not showing every single
possible combination and negative
numbers whole numbers you know I put in
a twelfth because I thought I was being
hilarious and then I immediately thought
I wasn't gonna put negatives on this
diagram so I regret that for two reasons
opening the negative can and the
expression on your face so I'm gonna
make that a plus there we own it in fact
this whole sheet of paper is just gonna
be the reals positive you know it works
for negative reals what am I saying have
the negatives it's fine but the sheet is
are all the reals and inside here I've
put whole numbers and then I've put
rational numbers if you you can
obviously get complex numbers coming up
we're not gonna do that we're gonna stay
down here and I'm gonna really work our
way out until we get a greater distance
out then numberphile has ever gone
before
right we're going for the new
numberphile record how far out into the
weird reals can we go but we're done
rational next one up there constructible
x' and these often aren't mentions you
don't have to add this in as a category
but I quite like constructible x' more
importantly what people tend to go for
the next one out of the algebraic okay
so Simon did a fantastic video about
algebraic numbers and when you go
outside transcendental numbers I mean
this number is really really important
and no one knew and so a lot of the
number categories refer to in or out of
these different sets so rational numbers
are everything inside the blue line
irrational numbers are everything
outside the blue line you've got
constructible numbers or anything inside
the purple line and constructible
numbers are out
this and this light blue line out here
algebraic numbers everything inside
there and transcendental numbers
everything outside of there and so
constructible numbers are things that
you can construct with a pencil and a
compass and a ruler so Phi you can do
that the golden ratio because you can do
routes five so you can get Phi you can
do route - that lives in here it's kind
of fun
algebraic numbers are the solution to an
algebraic equation if it's a square root
or lower you can put it in constructible
you can draw it if it's higher than that
you can't so the cube root of two is an
algebraic number and then outside
algebraic you've got beyond that right
so you've got things like pi pi lives
out here pi is transcendental e is
transcendental the natural log of two
that's out there things that aren't a
nice neat solution to another break
equation I out there right this is how
people tend to categorize all the
numbers this is the fringe of kind of
what we understand in mathematics and
what we've done on numberphile so it was
the first number that was proven to be
transcendental and so that was proven in
1873 so reasonably recent given that
some of these are thousands of years old
when you existed boo didn't know where
it went
pi we didn't know where that went pi was
proven to be out here in 1882 so e ^ pi
was proven to be out here in only 1934
so that was a more recent one with mesh
to prove is out there and there are
loads which we don't know PI to the e we
don't know e to the e we don't know pi
to the PI we don't know right these are
all on the cusp we know that one of e
times pi or e plus pi
one or more of those are transcendental
we don't know which or both right but we
know at least one of them is most
numbers that we know are algebraic sit
around here and we don't know if they're
definitely transcendental or if there's
still a a break for the most part we
haven't got a clue right if you look at
the entry for transcendental numbers on
Wikipedia or math world there's a list
here's the only ones we know and that's
it right some of our favorite big ol
numbers grams number in here googolplex
in here right whole numbers doesn't
matter how big it is it's in there there
are infinitely many whole numbers but
there are also infinitely many rational
numbers same infinity there are
infinitely many constructible numbers in
the major break numbers but all
countable infinity is the smallest
infinity possible do many of these
numbers in here and there is one more
circuit out you know what should we
check on the last one I can add another
loop and it cleans up all of these and
it puts them all in a neat bow this is
the collection of computable numbers
computer what was that what this means
we can compute them so we can compute e
we can compute PI right it's not the
solution to a nice equation but I can
write down a system by which you will
get the decimal place right and so we do
this we print them out on a very long
bit of paper rolling out on a runway
it's hilarious right well here on a
runway because for some reason Brady has
printed out the first 1 million digits
of pi so this came down to Alan Turing
in 1936 and everyone remembers that
shirring invented the computer with the
Turing machine and that was in his paper
on computable numbers he was looking at
if you can compute all numbers and he
showed there are a number that exist out
here but we just don't know what they're
I call them the dark numbers right all
these numbers that we know they exist
cheering showed us but they're they're
so hard to grasp and occasionally we see
them but not often well why isn't pi out
here we can compute pi
well it takes forever like I could write
down a infinite series which gives you
PI and I can give you the rules for
writing out the infinite series and I
could write them on a postcard or some
finite amount of space and go here are
the rules for coding pi
you're going to have to do them forever
but the rules are finite so for
everything else in here I can write a
description of how to get all the digits
out here
they're only definable by writing out
all the digits and no and that's
actually most numbers in here this is
the countable infinity land right
there's there's there's infinitely many
of these but the smallest infinitely
many our here is a bigger infinitely
many so the vast majority for the
strongest definition of vast majority
you can come up with odd numbers are not
computable so we
in this nice little island of numbers
that make sense and then outside is this
vast vast world of all the reels which
are only definable by writing out their
digits and we're spotted a few so
there's one court the trial in constant
I'll have to double check I got that
right
Triton vaguely speaking is the
probability for a certain way of writing
a computer program if you generate a
computer program at random if it will
run and come to a stop
right and that probability is a naive
way of describing it and it depends on
how you write a program so in fact there
are lots of these constants but we know
they're all out here the only way to get
them is to work out every single digit
individually there's no equation of
algorithm that spits it out it's an
uncomputable number and they're so
mysterious and hard to understand the
fringes of our comprehension of numbers
but they're out there and the scary
thing is most numbers are out there how
can we even know one of them it seemed
it feels like an unknowable unknown it
is insane that we even know a couple of
them because when I described the
numbers out here I'm super hand way
because I don't understand them right
I've read I like I've tried I read the
paper I'm like man this is beyond me
like is the maths to try and grapple
with the numbers out here is insane but
what's incredible is we have done it
right so if you look up uncomputable
numbers there are a few examples of ones
out here although interestingly when you
get these weird numbers you can you can
just you can kind of make artificial
ones okay so I'm now gonna kind of ruin
my lovely neat diagram by putting on a
whole new category this is the category
of what are called normal numbers which
is a bit of a silly name it just means
that every possible sub grouping of
digits is equally likely to be in there
and a lot of people say like for example
pie everyone goes your phone number
somewhere in pi your name is somewhere
in pi the complete works of William
Shakespeare it's a digit somewhere in PI
we don't know that we can move PI into
here which we may yet do we may yet do
it maybe in here everyone seems to think
it is all the digits we've checked imply
it's in here but we
not yet managed to prove that we don't
know if pies in here we don't know if
ease in here we don't know if route twos
in here even though for all of these if
you look to the digits you can find any
string of digits you want I found my
name in all of them right because
they've all got a lot of digits that are
suitably random and you can find sub
strings in there but we've not managed
to prove any of those in normal numbers
would you like to see one number we have
nice to prove so this I love this number
it's called Tampa nouns constant is
normal it's one of the few numbers we
know is normal constant constant in that
it's just climbing under the age it's so
champions constant is one of the few
numbers we know is normal and it goes
zero point one two three I've memorized
it four five six seven eight nine well
10 1 0 11 12 and it's just all the whole
numbers 14 15 16 and so on let's check
this one a:1920
and so on that's it really is it really
is I call this an artificial number
because Champa noun just went can I find
a number which is normal and he came up
with this procedure he just went right
you just put all the numbers in order
all the integers in base 10 and you
don't and it's true right because
whatever you want to find it's in there
eventually because it's just all the
whole numbers listed out and then turned
into digits but that's all numbers are
right whole bunch of digits perfectly
valid number right but and it is
computable right so actually it's like
the least efficient way of doing it it
is there's a slightly more efficient one
the Copeland air dish number is the same
idea but only the primes so it's 2 3 5 7
1 1 1 3 so on 1 7 etc so exactly the
same idea slightly more efficient it's
also normal so we didn't start with
these numbers and go I wonder if they're
normal these people sat down and went
I'm gonna make a normal number how can I
do that and they generated these now
champignons number is transcendental so
this is it in base 10
you can do it in different bases and it
is computable it is normal and is
transcendental so transcendental means
it's outside algebraic it's there and
not the speed of light champ announce
constants it's in this part of the
diagram so the only normal numbers we
know for certain are artificial ones
that are being constructed for that
purpose we have never started with a
number and then discovered it is normal
we have no test there is no process for
taking a number and proving it's normal
like mathematics like hopefully one day
we'll have a test currently we don't
which means all the normal numbers we
have are artificially generated we are
yet to take anything from here and show
that it's allowed to move over this line
there's an elephant on your diagram
there is it over here well very easy
thing you should say that Brady this
section is empty and this is the only
properly empty section of the diagram
now up here we had that one number whose
name I couldn't remember properly Tritan
oh this set of numbers do with whether
our program will halt we've got numbers
in this category right so this section
we've got numbers this is completely
empty and that's because the only normal
numbers we know of are ones that we made
for that purpose and the fact that we
made them for that purpose means we have
a rule for generating them which means
they must be computable to have an
uncomputable normal number would be
incredible but this is currently empty
but we have managed to prove one thing
nice to prove that most numbers are
normal and most numbers are uncomputable
so actually this is the biggest section
this is numbers right this is a trivial
blip right in the world not this is
where numbers are right and we have none
so in the main category of numbers where
all the numbers are apart from a few
trivial side-effects all right
we know zero of them you know as
mathematicians we think we're getting
somewhere but up until now we have found
none of the numbers hi everyone this
isn't a formal sponsorship it's just to
let you know that Matt who you just
watched has a new book out that I think
you're like humble pie that's what it
looks like
a comedy of maths errors that's a great
cover if you'd like to be among the
first people to get your hands on I was
actually the first person to be given
one just quietly then go to the website
in the video description it's math skier
that's Matt's website and by buying it
from there
not only will you get one of the first
hardcopy editions you'll get a copy
signed by Matt as you know Matt's been a
huge friend a numberphile over the years
and just one of the small ways we can
show our appreciation is to check out
his book now I know what you're all
thinking if this is about mathematical
errors does it contain the parker square
now I don't want to give away anything I
know people don't like spoilers so yes
it does and if you can't get enough Matt
Parker in your life he is also a guest
in the most recent episode of the
numberphile podcast have you seen the
numberphile podcast yet have you
listened to it check it out I'll also
put links down below
Tritan